[Musica]
[Applauso]
ognuno di noi
ha un suo metronomo interno che sa
scandire il ritmo del cambiamento
il ritmo della propria vita
e fa più o meno così
un semplicissimo respiro
oggi vorrei raccontarvi di una bambina
vorrei cercare di materializzarla nella
vostra mente quindi vi chiedo la
cortesia di provare lo so è difficile
dopo pranzo perché rischio di non
trovarvi più però vorrei chiedervi la
cortesia di chiudere per un attimo gli
occhi
e provare ad immaginare una bambina
vestita di rosa con un vestitino
talmente voluminoso la ricordare una
nuvola
bionda con i capelli lisci decisamente
spettinati
e negli occhi quel desiderio di
diventare una principessina a modo
obbediente che volteggiando attenzione
volteggiando non camminando lancia
petali dietro di se
avete chiara questa immagine fatata dopo
il pranzo
mi piace quello che ha detto sì perché
ti vedo presente
ok ora riaprire gli occhi tornate alla
realtà con me perché in realtà vorrei
dirvi che quella bambina non è mai
esistita il suo posto c'era questa
ora la vita era già scritta per quanto
io volessi cercare di essere un
angioletto intonato mia grande coro
armonico ed angelico della vita io
trascorrevo le giornate vestita in
questo modo dimentico di dirvi che non
era carnevale a questo era il mio out
with normale un giorno qualunque della
mia vita qualunque in casa vestita così
con questi bei baffetti
nonché il demonio si fosse impossessato
di me tra l'altro un demonio dire moggi
fluido con il fulmine di flash gordon
sulla pancia
no ero io che mi era impossessata di lui
per così dire per volergli rubare un
ruolo l'intro di me scalpitava forte la
necessità di differenziarli quindi da
una parte avevo i miei amichetti belli
vestiti di bianco come gli angioletti
dall'altra parte quelle fighissime
bambine vestite
di che cosa era veste di rosa
e quindi per differenziarli avevo
semplicemente due alternative all'ora o
mi sarei trasformato in una big babol
panna e fragola gigantesca in modo da
unire i due colori il bianco e rosa o
per meglio dire le due personalità o
avrei vestito i panni del cattivo
dell'imperfetto
e il cattivo cosa fa
il cattivo nei film cambia si trasforma
si evolve molto di più che il
protagonista buono che è molto spesso un
pochino prevedibile
fin da piccola io ero convinta
ragazzi ragazze signori signori
convintissima che tutto si potesse
cambiare ed in un certo senso fu così
crescendo diventare una bambina a modo
le principessine
pacifica che giocava giochi pacifici e
soprattutto propensa al dialogo e quindi
diventa i questa ragazzina
nonostante ancora oggi io stia cercando
di capire come mai gli incisivi siano
cresciuti più di me
comunque quel tempo
il disagio la guerra che stavo
combattendo non era esterna non aveva il
suono delle pistole giocattolo quel
laser no no
era tutto dentro di me
pensiero dopo pensiero
pensiero dopo pensiero e i pensieri sono
rumori
la solitudine un rumore la separazione
un rumore
gli abbandoni sono rumori le malattie
sono rumori
e cosa fa la maggior parte delle persone
davanti al rumore
apa urla più forte
indossa cuffie noise canceling
sull'anima per non sentire per fingere
che vada tutto bene una perfetta bolla
di non rumore una perfetta bolla di
silenzio
ma in un altro the licks vi ho
raccontato che tuttavia il silenzio non
esiste e quindi la bolla esplode
esplode e lascia spazio a quello che è
il rumore dell'anima
e quindi che cosa fa la ragazzina di
prima siccome non può sconfiggerlo lo
abbraccia lo trasforma
fin da piccola ho sempre creduto che il
non probabile non volesse dire
impossibile che il fatto che qualcosa
fosse per così dire non inquadrato non
significasse che fosse sbagliato che il
fatto che non esistesse una professione
non significasse che non si potesse
creare e dalle loro preso tutti i rumori
dell'anima dei luoghi
negli oggetti ed ho promesso loro che
sarebbero diventati il mio strumento
musicale
ho promesso loro che da fallimenti
sarebbero diventati musica si sarebbero
trasformati in un lavoro e così è stato
ora qualcuno intelligente
particolarmente acuto in questa stanza e
immagino che tutti voi lo siate tranne
me potrebbe dire ma che lavoro è e il
lavoro del rimanere in ascolto della
vera il coraggio di farlo non solo di
noi stessi ma di tutto quello che ci sta
intorno
e la missione di prendere qualcosa di
fallimentare di rumoroso di brutto di
imperfetto e trasformarle in qualcosa di
perfetto
e si è un lavoro
e il brutto che si prende una sonante
rivincita con il bello
è un lavoro perché ricordate dove la
vista dimentica
l'orecchio ricorda l'orecchio e sempre
in ascolto
quando piangiamo quando ridiamo quando
dormiamo
l'orecchio ascolta sempre
compongo colonne sonore utilizzando il
rumore e giuro c'è anche chi mi paga per
farlo e quando mi chiedono perché non
tanto perché mi pagano
ma perché utilizzo il rumore mi sono
complicata la vita perché niente nessuno
strumento musicale può essere
imprevedibile come la vita perché
nessuno strumento musicale sta sbagliare
gioire fallire come la vita
perché il rumore delle nostre vite ci
rende tutti
compositori
occorre semplicemente imparare ad
accordare il rumore è solo questo il
trucco
imparare ad accordare il rumore
quando
quando rifletto sui suoni della vita
quando rifletto sul suono dei pianti sul
suono delle risate
ecco allora mi chiedo ma qual è la vera
ragione per la quale esistiamo per fare
per dire per essere
e per ascoltare
perché nel momento in cui impariamo ad
ascoltare tutto ciò che ci sta intorno
il più piccolo dettaglio della vita
allora iniziamo renderci conto di quando
di quanto tutto sia realmente vivo
perché tutti i fallimenti della nostra
vita compongono quello che io chiamo lo
spartito dell'anima dove non c'è il
giusto e lo sbagliato ma soltanto
l'intenzione di ascoltare ed ascoltarsi
e quella di non farlo
e quando
mi sono ritrovata a riflettere
su uno strumento musicale da potervi
suonare oggi ho pensato a quel metronomo
interno che vi ho fatto ascoltare
all'inizio che tutti noi abbiamo
e poi mi son detta mano una macchina
capiente posso portare tutti i miei
strumenti musicali e quindi li ho
portati
ora io so
che da quando sono entrata la vostra
concentrazione era fermo ferma immobile
su questo tubo su questo tubo di cartone
e lo so perfettamente perché insomma
si sa che l'ha vista destrà è questo il
problema alla vista la vista distrae
e parolo l'udito attrae ed è decisamente
differente
e quindi ho portato tutti i miei
strumenti musicali con me e oggi vorrei
suonarli per voi perché nel momento in
cui ci accorgiamo che il più piccolo
dettaglio inanimato ininfluente
indifferente a una sua sonorità che sia
vivo o non vivo che sia di cartone o di
moquette
tutto prende vita
e quindi ho portato con me i miei
strumenti musicali e sono
un bicchiere
ambientalisti e plastica riciclata ve lo
dico subito suona bene ma e plastica
riciclata dopodiché un tubo di cartone
chi non ha un tubo di cartone in tasca e
poi un altro paio di cose che vorrei
mostrarvi allora sono le chiavi di casa
che spero di ricordarmi altrimenti vi
invito entrate direttamente la notte che
non mi spaventa niente un po di carta
forno io non cucino ma utilizzo della
carta forno come strumento musicale
un interruttori know e un elastico
no scusate mi ci sono anche delle noci
che sono talmente secche da suonare
benissimo quindi quando avete delle noci
magari aspettate a mangiarle
suoneranno benissimo per voi e quindi
inizierei
suonando qualcosa per voi questo è un
microfono un microfono binaurale non
entro nel dettaglio perché rischierei di
essere di un noioso pazzesco l'ho
costruito per voi e ripercorrere
ripresenta riproduce il suono
che noi ascoltiamo con la nostra testa
quindi queste due orecchie di silicone
sono esattamente quello iniziamo così
[Applauso]
[Musica]
di registrerai sarebbe bellissimo quindi
non eravate appesantiti dal pranzo e
questo mi fa molto piacere
la musica non si iscrive con la matita
ma con la gomma
questo perché non servono
orchestre pompose per raccontare
un'emozione
non servono
amor rumore lo amo profondamente
però attenzione
si può armonizzare tutto qualsiasi
rumore può essere trasformato in musica
ma c'è un unico rumore che non diventerà
mai melodia che rimarrà brutalmente
imperfetto ed è il rumore delle parole
non dette
dei rimpianti e del tempo perso e
credetemi so di cosa parlo
siate
[Applauso]
si affaccia
siate la più bella colonna sonora della
vostra pip grazie
[Applauso]